i just want to say thank you a quick
thank you to everybody who has bought a
ticket to come and see the direva ceo
live show
anywhere in the uk i can't believe i'm
saying this but we launched a second
night at the london palladium
and it sold out almost straight away so
we're going to do two nights in february
at the london palladium the dire ceo
live is just a
very unique musical
moving
personal development-centric empowering
experience for two hours in london in
glasgow in birmingham and in newcastle
taking place next year at the start of
the year i would love for you to come
i'd love to see you there
the show is completely sold out
everywhere but glasgow in newcastle we
have tickets on sale now
so if you're listening to this and you
trust me when i say it's something worth
coming to
the link is in the description below if
you're in glasgow or you're in newcastle
there are still a few tickets available
now i hope to see you there if they're
laughing it's fine if they're not it
ain't this is the russell howard we have
never seen before when you're low it
leaves you mentally fragile but then
that makes you work hard and go again
because you know the excitement you get
from making them laugh it's an unhealthy
treadmill but at the end of that
treadmill there is this
incredible cherry
that's what happiness is figure out a
healthier way of being the best you
without it being so draining to realize
what you have there will always be sort
of shimmering
lights of hope in in the misery but
sometimes somebody has to help you find
them
when he died it was just this
sledgehammer to your heart where you
just go
jesus one of the
one of the
one of the good souls isn't here anymore
[Music]
russell howard i've watched russell
howard on tv for years and years and
years and of all the podcasts i've done
russell and this conversation was the
most stark difference between the person
i've seen on tv
and the person i had a conversation with
today
i think your mind is going to be blown
he's got a new netflix show coming out
called lubricant and the reason it's
called lubricant is because he believes
comedy and laughter is the lubricant
that allows us to deal with the pain of
life
and we talk about the pain of his life
we talk about everything and in this
conversation
there's more tears
recently i did an episode on this
podcast with jimmy carr and the
resounding feedback we got was we've
never seen that jimmy carr before
i have a suspicion in fact i know
that people are going to say the same
about this conversation this is the
russell howard we have never seen before
and it's an incredibly inspiring
valuable
vulnerable russell howard it's the side
as a russell howard fan that i wish i'd
seen more of
i have a feeling you're going to be
really surprised so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
dire over ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
i'm funny because of my mum and i'm
determined because of my dad
you said that right i did say that yeah
i felt like that was the beginning of a
riddle
like you were sort of a gollum figure
trying to understand yeah can you
explain that to me please
um
my mum is a
a warm
twinkly-eyed little lady who is
inadvertently funny all the time has no
idea of her power
is
just naturally
uh bright
and joyful
if you ever feel
that you're kind of getting used to
hotels and the humdrum life of oh here
we are in another place um
take my mum with you separate rooms
and
watch her reaction when she goes into a
hotel room because it reminds you of how
you used to be
oh really jesus christ they've got
kettles they've got tea bags they've got
a trouser press look
like she's so excited and happy by the
world
and
my dad is um
a very quiet
unbelievably determined man who
you know when we were kids we'd sort of
he'd have us mix in cement
um we'd be sort of like
you know building kind of walls with him
plastering as a kid i remember watching
my dad plaster
and he was trying to keep this kind of
wall up
and he screamed to himself come on david
and sort of even at 11 i was going
that's a bit much
um so i have these kind of two very
different uh dominant personalities that
kind of
raised me who i love dearly both but
they are
very very different you know my dad
challenged me to a press-up competition
recently
um at a family barbecue and he beat me
he did um 68
he did yeah and he's uh
65 years old and
uh yeah remember this story this sums my
dad up
i had a school report when i was 11 and
the teacher said um what russell needs
to know is that he can't do everything
and i kind of go home and you know that
moment you give the report and your dad
looks and he goes what does this mean
you go well the teacher says i can't do
everything he goes why'd you say that
i just think that i can i think i can do
anything if i put my mind to it and my
dad goes you've got to go down that
school now and tell her that
so i have to walk back to the school
yeah and i kind of go in and go my dad
says i can do anything and you're not
allowed to say that i can't
which is a pretty you know incredible
thing to do but you know made school
tough
so yeah very different
what about brothers and sisters
i have a brother uh daniel who's an
amazing human being very funny um
and i have a sister who is an actress
who's uh also incredible um
they're very different as well
um i'm very close to my brother not so
much to my sister we sort of all my
brother we just played football together
as kids
and oddly kerry is in the same world as
me now and is kind of a bafta nominated
actress she was in um
him and her bbc3 and super talented and
yeah a great human being
they're a lovely bunch but very strange
my family it's like being in a pogue
song when you go to
kind of christmas parties around our way
do you know what i mean yeah it's sort
of you know those like
i remember weirdly the funeral of my nan
and granddad
um it was separate it sounded like they
it was packed
but but that feeling sometimes when you
go to a funeral and you're so proud to
have the same blood as the people in the
room i kind of feel that whenever i'm
back with my family in the west country
there's
there's such a
lunacy and energy to them that i adore
and feel so kind of
delighted to be part of you know it's
kind of
yeah
um jimmy car said something to me which
i've been waiting to ask another
comedian there's a stereotype that
comedians are funny because they're
depressed yeah but jimmy carl said
that's wrong he said you've really got
to ask a comedian who in their family is
sick
um because he says that much of his
comedic genius or his desire to please
people came from
um trying to make a family member happy
or trying to ease moments of tension
in the family dynamic when he was
younger um do you resonate with that at
all yeah yeah completely um that
my dad
my dad is
you know is successful and super serious
but
used to lose his mind watching kind of
billy connolly or watching have i got
news for you so he would like howl with
laughter and
we sort of figured out
the way to break dad's serious
energy
was to make him laugh
you know so definitely it was kind of
there's no tension if people like i've
got a line in my new special which is
laughter is the lubricant that makes
life livable
and it it you know it really
it soothes tensions and it's a bandage
that gets over cracks definitely you
know and then it's sort of this thing
that you when you discover you you know
you can make people laugh it's so
addictive and you can literally create
your own energy
and like you do in arena there's 15 000
people there you're orchestrating this
almost societal orgasm
where
they're kind of like lost in laughter
together it's
you feel like a necromancer man it's the
best
and i think jim's right in the that
that initial spark comes from
probably i'm thinking of other comedians
as well as myself it's sort of that
sense of
you know
like i've got a lazy eye so that was a
you know so i became funny to deflect
and do jokes about my eyes to get to
stop people looking at them and then you
kind of realize okay this is kind of
cool or if you're a bit thick or if
you're not good at football or you don't
fit in you can kind of
sort
of re-brand yourself in a strange way
through humor and then you can you can
create your own
kind of energy
that sounds kind of wanky but do you
know what i mean of course i do because
there's there's also another stereotype
which is that people who are slightly um
slightly bigger
but tend to be really bubbly and have
funny personalities and comedians as
well which is would fit that kind of
idea that it's a it's a tool of
deflection yeah from
something else you know they don't want
them to focus on
um you talk about it being linked
heavily linked to self-esteem as well
and you're yeah
yeah what's odd the further you get into
it you realize
that
it's so much fun doing stand-up um
and it's such a wild drug effectively
because you're doing these massive gigs
about 2 000 people and everyone's
laughing or 15 000 people you're in new
york you're doing a gig in finland and
you can't quite get over it and then as
a consequence it's quite hard to sit
down and watch the tv and be normal
and um
so you're kind of chasing that sort of
high and it's about
the real
the real skill is trying to figure out
the sort of
work life balance
you know
i'm speaking to somebody whose uh house
is above
work but you know what i mean it's like
see the only the only way around is to
sort of integrate it really
but like i don't know i've been doing
stand-up since i was 18 i remember doing
the first gig and it felt like it was
you sort of discovered a mechanism
through which you can do life that
everything
sad good happy weird peculiar can go
through this sausage maker and you can
then uh
understand life figure it out
but also that's a very strange way to to
do it because you you you're
you know you're using the stage to kind
of um
uh dissect yourself
but the aim is always funny but i don't
know of a better way to do it than to
kind of make sense of the world
and the funny thing about all comics is
guaranteed if they find themselves in a
strange situation sometimes a
heartbreaking situation in life
there's always a little part of your
brain going it could be a bit in this
and it's that horrible sort of
you know sort of disease that we have
that you can't ever truly be
there because there's always a little
bit of you whether you're seinfeld or
you know taylor thompson or bill burr or
chappelle or whatever
your brain is going yep there's stuff in
this you know i mean as you're having as
you're getting beaten up or whatever
your brain i remember getting
mugged in brighton when i was 18 and at
and
this this guy shouted to me come back
i'm a police officer he clearly wasn't
and i said no you're not you're a
monster and as i said it i went yeah
this could be quite funny i reckon like
but i'm literally running away i'm
terrified but my brain is going yeah
probably build a little bit about that
and it's i think all comics that i know
have that
thing where
reality is always auditioning to find
its way into your set
wow
i could uh i could get out of hand and
you could start willing misfortune this
is the weird thing yeah well but
well exactly but it's that's the problem
yeah we haven't got any jokes just
walking around dressed as a clown going
to like a [ __ ] zoo
there's got to be something in this but
yeah you're right it's but
it's sort of about keeping life open a
bit and keeping the third eye open
really probably that's the same of all
creatives where you kind of
you
or all people really like you have to
notice the thing the things that niggle
you and if you're talking about them
whether it's you know like in my last
special i had a big bit about kind of
young women self-harming i couldn't i
was like what like one in four women
self-harm and i was like i couldn't get
my head around that and i just knew i
had to talk about it on stage
and yesterday i saw this lady
complaining because the foam
in her cup
wasn't at the top of her cup
and i for the rest of that morning i
couldn't
i couldn't get my head around it just
how do you get the confidence to
complain about your foam
not being there and i know somehow
that's going to end up in a show
somewhere
that's the way i kind of operate really
i sort of see these little things or
and they kind of
make a note on my phone and they
gradually kind of make their way
you know interesting like collecting
dots from society and then figuring out
how they form well i think that i know
chris martin does a similar thing where
you just make little notes of lyrics and
woody allen does similar thing woody
allen will just write a load of stuff
and then he puts it in a um
a draw and then when he comes to write a
film he just gets the draw out
empties all these notes that he's been
making for the last six months and
figures out what the film's going to be
and i that's a lot easier than sort of
writing from a blank page because you
can then
finesse your kind of
thoughts in the field when you're in the
laboratory as it were
you said something there which i find
really interesting and i think is
there's kind of um
almost analogies for life within which
is after you've come off stage to
thousands of people in an arena yeah you
then go home and have to like sit in
front of the tv yeah the anti-climax
dealing with like that consistent
high then low
it feels like a lot emotionally because
that's like a huge adrenaline surge and
then even like physiologically that it
feels like that must be non not natural
yeah have a consequence
yeah christ that's deep let's hope it
doesn't but yeah you're right it's it's
yeah
every comedian when they're in the
middle of a tour needs a really really
good box set
like you know it's like you need
succession
you need mad men you need something to
get you through because yeah it's sort
of
otherwise
like if you're trying to maintain that
high um you know if you're sort of
drinking and you're doing drugs or
whatnot it's going to make it harder to
be
that version it's kind of like whereas
if you're a musician you can still sing
the song that they want you to sing if
you're on kind of coke or like or you're
pissed up it's kind of hard to be
a good comic for a long time
if you kind of you know on drinking
drugs
so yeah you have to sort of develop this
kind of way of like reintegrating your
life
but also it's nonsense as well it's just
it's it's fun make belief like and and
also what's important is kind of you
know going for a meal with your wife and
and and hanging out and seeing friends
and and there's joy in that you know and
you see it you you have to
you have to try you have to plan fun i
think that that's the crucial thing you
have to come right we'll go on holiday
and we'll go to that restaurant and
we'll watch this film because i think
like you say it's the sitting
and the
and the waiting that is very difficult
to compete with the
the innate rush that you get from
stand-up because of what you do
professionally do you find it harder to
enjoy
the sitting and the waiting and the meal
where you're sat there just you know and
the holiday where you're sat on the deck
chair
not like i normally what i love about
holidays i don't know what your feelings
are about them but by the end of like 10
days
i'm ready to go back to my life because
holidays remind me of how much i love my
life
and that's the thing so you need to have
that kind of i'm a real sit in the sun
you know read some books
um listen to podcasts whatever and then
kind of go again but i like the recharge
of it if there was a if there was a
thing where you could literally plug
yourself in like a mobile phone i would
happily do that on a beach do you know
what i mean and then kind of go again
but i'm not really
a when i'm in holiday mode i'm not
really a culture vulture i'm kind of a
sit down
plonk book sun
relax
get ill because i've been putting it off
do you know what i mean your body just
kind of gets a bit sick and then you
kind of go again how about you do you
are you a relaxer
uh i think i'm a forced relaxer right
yeah i think my girlfriend is the reason
why i would go on holiday and i think
she's also the reason why i would be
present on holiday and right she's the
reason why i'd go and look at like a
castle or something okay but a castle
like whatever she would want to look at
but okay i think if it was just up to me
i wouldn't go and i wouldn't do it and
even if i did go i wouldn't leave the
hotel room yes there's like strong
evidence for that because whenever i've
gone to speak in a country or whatever i
don't leave the hotel room yeah no
desire to do anything but just be on my
phone or laptop so it's pretty sad but i
think you know that's why it's fortunate
that i have a girlfriend
yeah but it's also on that thing as well
of like you clearly
with the job you do you clearly love it
as well i love it yeah so that's the
thing if you're fortunate enough there
are so many there are billions of people
who are who are who
you know live for the weekend do your
job punch in job you don't like get your
money
smash your weekend try and find your fun
if you're
one of the
there are so few people in this world
that truly have a thing that they do
that they get paid for that they adore
you just gotta get hold of it bro and
just like there's no shame
but it just seems peculiar to the
outside so you gotta be how obsessed you
get about your job or i would get about
stand up or there was a documentary
about the comedy store um on uh sky
recently and i watched it is incredible
it was a beautiful kind of summer's day
and i smashed the whole thing one of the
best days i've ever had in my life
because it was incredible and it evoked
this kind of the comedy store from the
sort of the 70s and the 80s and jay leno
and all this and it just
you know i was like we need a time
machine we need to go back to to those
times at the comedy store
but this because i love stand-up and i
kind of you know
it's you have to be with people that
understand
your passions because you can't fake it
you can't go let's go to the castle if
you're not a go to the castle guy do you
know what i mean but you're right you
can be you can have help to look at the
castle and then you realize when you get
to the castle that's just a really nice
castle yeah i wouldn't have come had you
not completely yeah yeah
and we're not staying for ages of the
castle
[Music]
um but you start writing so on that
point of finding your passion and
pursuing it you started writing jokes at
14. yeah why are you doing your research
yeah yeah i had an old computer and uh
yeah i kind of i watched lee evans video
with my my mate craig
um and uh it blew my mind because when i
was a kid standup really wasn't on tv
that you'd have like a billy connolly
tape uh
you'd have like have i got news for you
it's a big show or bottom or
uh
um shooting stars it's that kind of era
but standard wasn't really a thing um
and he was the first sort of person that
i'd seen who kind of
was just funny wasn't an alpha and i was
like wow he like it was mind-blowing i
just thought i think i could be
that's sort of a bit like how i'm funny
like you know what i mean and um me and
craig just wore that tape out we just
watched it over and over and over
and um
and i didn't tell anyone about i just
started writing these little kind of
jokes and routines and ideas
that um none of which were any good but
it just became like my little it was
like my little fun place to go to every
so often goes i'm gonna write some of my
jokes did you perform them to anybody at
that page my first ever gig was in
bristol a place called virgin murph and
i took all these jokes that i've been
writing since i was 14 and i whittled it
down to my best 20
and i did it there at virgin mirth i
followed a guy
who was eating a banana with a spoon
singing the theme tune to the sweeney
and uh another bloke that was sort of
like his act was to punch himself in the
face so in a sense it didn't really
matter how bad my 14 year old stuff was
um but yeah so that was it and then i
kind of some of it's stuck some of it
didn't but it was all like i had this
bit about like how did captain kirk get
through the entire i wrote this when i
was 14. but how did captain kirk get
through all the star trek episodes
without once flicking spock's ears so
that was one of my first so and i
thought i think it's all right it's not
bad it's not bad but
that was the first joke i ever kind of
told
and one of the things i found quite
peculiar in your story is that your your
dad um
really pushed you to give comedy a go
yeah and that that seems
of all the guests i sit here with the
thing that has typically made them um
famous or well-known or successful yeah
they their parents were usually quite
against it and would much rather of them
got a quote-unquote real job yes so what
were you doing at the time um and
yeah why was your dad supportive of it
when you know at a time when that's
probably not considered a
highly
profitable high chance of success career
yeah i was working at the rac
in bristol i had a part-time job
um and i was also doing stand-up and i
because i started stand up at university
and then finish my degree went home
and was just kind of doing probably
three gigs a week
for you know 50 quid a pop was like
sometimes 100 quid a pop that kind of
thing and um
alongside this kind of like shift at the
roc
and it was i was kind of like i'd have a
gig in lincoln and then i'd have to
drive back to get to work and it was it
was kind of like knackering and my dad
basically
i went weirdly not to name drop but i
was talking to matthew mcconaughey about
this and it's a very similar thing where
his dad
when he told his dad he wasn't going to
become a lawyer he was going to become a
comedian he um an actor
his dad said don't half-ass it and that
was a similar reaction to my dad my dad
basically was like right if you want to
do this you're 21
go for it give yourself a year
don't stop
put everything into it and then if if
it's not happening in a year you stop
you get a proper job and i kind of i
i really respected that option that he
gave me do you know what i mean it was
like i'll be fine it was like don't [ __ ]
around
properly go for it don't do three gigs a
week do five gigs a week just do that
and then see where you are in a year and
um
i was at the edinburgh festival i had
about like eight days left from this
kind of like contract and
my now agent saw me at the edinburgh
festival
have
like a really good gig
and he kind of said oh does it always go
that well and i say all the time you mad
yeah um but it was i was doing lots of
sort of improvising and stuff like that
it was quite hit and miss back then
and then we went for
went for a meal he gave me i used to
have a a thing called the comedy network
where it's like 30 gigs around
universities and that day he booked me
into these 30 gigs that were at the time
i still remember the money it's 150
pounds per gig
spreading out into november
and but to work for um a comedy company
called avalon it's one of the biggest
kind of comedy producers in the in the
uk
and then he signed me and so
it worked and then i kind of moved to
london and kind of you know slowly kind
of
kept on keeping on i really i liked the
deadline that my dad gave me do you know
what i mean because it was kind of and i
i really respected it and he
he had this amazing quote on his office
that that said
something like i think it's by t e t s
eliot or t e elliot that said those who
dream by night in the dusty recesses of
their mind wake in the day to find that
all is vanity but the dreamers of the
day are dangerous for they act upon
their visions with open eyes and make
them happen
and that
is at the core of my dad so he's kind of
quite disciplined but he also has a [ __ ]
it go for it but yeah
i just went for it
but also because i loved it and i didn't
love working at the rsc and i didn't i'd
finish my degree and i knew what i
wanted to do and i just i just worked my
bollocks off man i did every gig you can
imagine but loved it and my brother used
to come to them we traveled down to
brighton
to do 10 minutes
and
you know we we'd have to sort of bunny
hop the car to reading station because
we didn't fill up and
you know it was it was real kind of fly
by the seat your pants stuff but
just
the best it was the best it was like
it's the best night out you go to
plymouth and you you know it's a six
hour round journey but you do
20 minutes and it goes great and then
the promoter says oh we'll get you back
and you're like brilliant i go back to
plymouth you know and um
yeah it's sort of all worked out
something is so interesting when i speak
to successful comedians because
it's one of the like purest forms of
like
insanely i say insanely but like
if you were trying to
reach a
lucrative outcome one of those like
insane paths
uh one of the most
insane pure
followings of one's passion because
it
seems to be the case that you follow
your this passion which doesn't promise
to ever pay you that well yeah or
promises no chance of success and you
follow it for years you paid
50 quid 100 quid yeah
and then i mean i speak to the ones that
were successful right
but when you look back on that period of
your life
and if i was to say well like what are
they what are the key things you've
identified hard work as one of them yeah
but what are like the key things that
made you
get here when so many
won't get here
hard work luck
um
natural talent
um perspiration
um and
but mostly and i would say luck is a big
thing luck and hard work are the big big
ones and and taking your opportunity and
having little
kind of moments and always listening to
the crowd as well because
it's sort of that thing where certainly
as a live comedian you can't [ __ ]
people like that there is you get a
tangible answer every time the laughter
is yes the silence is no
you just can't [ __ ] with that like
that's that is that there is a truth
to the to the gig if if they're laughing
it's fine if they're not it ain't and
that's the big thing really it's just
kind of you know
all great comedians listen to the
audience because they're all that
matters and
you can be critically lauded you can be
um you can win awards you know
but ultimately if if you don't hear
laughter you won't be here and it's and
you have to have new stuff that's the
big thing you have to you have to make
them laugh and constantly constantly
renew yourself that's the thing
um
to kind of to stick around
you make the audience laugh they all
burst out laughing they clap they say oh
you're amazing after the gig they say
we're gonna rebic you you're the best
person ever does that impact your
self-esteem in a positive way yeah of
course yeah imagine that but yeah it's
yeah it's the best man it's just but
that feeling when you do
the bright and comedian and you're 20
and you do 10 minutes and it goes really
well and stephen grant who is still the
booker at the brighton comedia says oh
we'll get you back for a 20. that
journey home does the best
or someone says are you going to do the
we're going to get you back to uh to
host
the lincoln student night and you're
like yeah do you want to do it monthly
yes and you build up this like little
following in lincoln because it's
it's
of course your self-esteem is just up
there because you feel like you're
a youth team footballer that's breaking
into the first thing that's how it must
feel like you feel like you're
kind of phil foden and you get these
little opportunities it's pretty similar
thing with footballers like what makes
phil foden probably that he has natural
talent he works his arse off and when
there's opportunities he's kind of
clinical enough to take advantage of
them do you know what i mean and learn
from mistakes that's the and comedy is
constantly about learning from mistakes
because you go you do new material it
doesn't work you you tweak it you tweak
it you tweak it until you get something
that that that kind of makes them laugh
we one would then assume that comedians
have like just tremendously high
self-esteem
if they're laughing yeah but then what
the the interesting as well is how
quickly it crumbles down if it goes
badly and i've got a friend of mine al
pitcher who's a comic in sweden and we
talk about this a lot where when you're
low
it
irrespective of what you've done before
you just feel like
like such deep
deep shame that you've been unable to
kind of make them laugh
but then that makes you work hard and go
again because you know the excitement
you get from making them laugh so it's
this it's an unhealthy treadmill but at
the end of that treadmill there is this
incredible cherry
deep deep shame
just because it's embarrassing it's like
you've you've tried to make
like even this i'm really enjoying this
it's really fun but it's very serious
and we've got like a little mini
audience over there i can hear and every
little laugh my brain's going that's
good
and when they're not i'm like
yeah totally just because you sort of
feel like
you know it's sort of that weird thing
for me laughter is truth and victory and
silence is failure but then the
interesting thing about that is when you
watch
a performance you actually realize that
of another comic you go wow there's real
power in the silence actually
which took me a long time to realize
because i was very initiated
just keep it up keep it up keep it up
and then you kind of you know you you
watch someone like chappelle
um for example and you go he's a real
master of the silence and you don't
you're not you don't lose
him
do you know me and you're not away
you're captivated
but it takes a really long time to feel
that you've earned the right to
captivate an audience
but there's captivation in silence but
who [ __ ] thinks they're captivating
that's the hardest thing i find is to
kind of
you can never know whether you've been
captivating or dull
because the sound is the same
i mean it's sort of that weird thing of
like
i mean i don't come off stage again was
that captivating or dull yeah um but
hopefully yeah
it's really interesting so when when you
have conversations like this because
there is no
like there's not huge amounts of
laughter because it's a serious
conversation i love chats like this this
is the best man but yeah go on i think
that's what i was basically asking was
um
when we when we have comedians come here
we've had russell kane we've had
obviously jimmy carr um
they do make a lot of jokes yeah even
before we're filming i think you know
jackal like put the microphone close to
jimmy carr's mouth and i think he said
something like um just keep it like a
fist away and he said that's what your
mother said yes
yeah
and it's almost like a um a tourette's
of humor which yes and i wonder how you
kind of get through life
like that and it almost feels like
uncontrollable yeah honestly that is the
best description of it like there's a
joke that i think sums up comedians
brains the best by a brilliant comedian
called uh mitch hedberg he he's no
longer with us one of the greatest
comedians of all time and this joke sums
up the brain that comedians have where
and i'll do his impression if there's
fans of mitch out there forgive me for
this but it works better if you try and
do is hear me kind of goes i'm mumble
man i mumble a lot off stage i'm a
mumbler so i'll be with my friend
and i'll i'll say something and he'll be
like what
and i'll say it again a little bit
louder and he'll be like i didn't hear
you
and then the third time i'll say and he
still can't hear me so i'll say it to
him but now i'm yelling at him that tree
is far away
and that's what it is it's this thing in
his head that's going on the trees the
way
and he it's a joke about the mania but
what you know about i was just saying
that trees over there that it's not
it's further away and it's that thing
the amount of times i've been with my my
wife and you sort of say sorry and you
know what [ __ ] about just i saw this
bin in primrose hill the other day that
genuinely said protect um
our birds so this was the line on the
bin protect our birds there's a picture
of like a
a bird
and respect their way of life and i just
went into this thing of like i don't
know you show respect to a [ __ ] but
like in my head i'm just kind of like i
didn't know there were disgruntled chaff
inches all over primrose hill i've never
seen that on the news of just kind of
going today a bird was the victim of of
uh you know of of somebody attacking him
and my brain was just like whirring
around with this and she can see i'm i'm
kind of full zombie oh he's just gone
[ __ ] what are you on about a [ __ ] bin
and it's sort of that that's kind of the
the way that comics brains are i think
that you you spend a lot of time playing
around in your head
um
and then you kind of go oh that might be
something you know like we would the
other day um
talked to a friend
about sperm donors
and somebody had had
uh
there was this website and on that you
could sort of get you could get your
batch
i said one of them was like um
uh you know
he was like six foot four swedish keen
reader
and um your really good job and you're
like yeah that's exactly what i'd say if
i was trying to flog spanx
you're not gonna kind of go you're a bit
of a loner
comes in every wednesday we've had to
stop it
but but my point being we were having a
chat about sperm donating and my brain
was sort of off in this
sort of fantasy land
where's the bit kind of like what i just
found it's so funny that i don't know
any true
six foot four high-achieving
intellectuals that kind of just get a
nip out to us bath into a pot yeah you
know what i mean it doesn't exist but
everyone's turned to tinder bye totally
but
the point is you spend a lot of time in
that kind of fun zone
um and that i think that's the brain
that a lot of comics have speaking of
that brain spiraling
when after you've done a gig or you know
can you remember a time where you like
go on google you go on the daily mail or
something you twitter and you look at
articles of what people are saying of
you and it has a really profound like
negative impact on your what you think
about yourself and you start to question
yourself i don't do it like i
i
came up in the days of uh myspace and
whatnot and that was i've never been on
twitter i've never been on facebook um
i do a bit of instagram it's the same
with reviews it's a very funny thing you
get a five-star review and your brain's
like exactly yep correct you get a
shitty review and you're like what the
[ __ ] and you realize
that you have to pay no heed to it the
only i mean it's flattering and it's
great and it's lovely to get nice
reviews and anyone who says otherwise is
[ __ ]
but it's with social media
you you you can't
it's too much to kind of
seek validation from people particularly
in the world that we live in
at the minute where you're having to
check to see if you've been correct for
you you're not going to be right for
everybody and some people will not like
a joke or some people suit you know you
just have to try and stay where you stay
where you are so
i i've definitely had times like that
when i was younger and it just crushes
you and you realize actually all i'm
doing is paying attention to
the really negative things that people
say
um and they'll be like you know one out
of 50 that's super horrible
um rather than focusing on on the kind
things and you realize actually my brain
focuses on the negative you go yeah
they're right actually yeah yeah yeah
yeah i am that yeah
yeah correct correct correct it just
doesn't make me
a better more functional human being it
just it hurts so i don't do it do you
know what i mean so i just kind of but
people must have said to you your agents
your manager said i'll get on twitter
that'll help
yeah well what what i do and what i love
about social media is i like making
things and then putting it on there
and so putting clips of stand up or the
tv show or whatever but i i i don't i'm
lucky
i have a i if i want to do comedy i can
go to a comedy club
and
it's a dark room and i can howl i can
scream or i can be silly i can do
whatever i want it's in a comedy club
social media is the worst comedy club in
the world
because people aren't there to laugh
jeremy everyone there is there to laugh
and there's this sort of lovely bonding
experience we're here for a reason
whereas social media some people
most people in the world are just up for
a hoot but some people
are looking to be to be angry or they're
looking to be enraged so it just seems
naive to put
humor into such a volatile club imagine
if it was a club called twitter right
hey do you want to come play twitter can
you imagine how hard that comedy club
would be you know what i mean and
so i just don't i don't bother with it
but i like making things that are
finished and then putting them out
but i kind of literally emailed them to
my agent than say oh we should put this
bit from the show on i don't even know i
haven't got my logins i don't know
really yeah just because
yeah but but but and also maybe it's
because i'm 41 and i kind of came up in
an era where stan that was still
playing clubs if you're if you're a
young guy now um
it must be completely different and
there's loads of kind of great comics
that have kind of come up through social
media
um
or through podcasts and i love that
because this particular podcast i think
with like young comics there's a real
air of punk about it where you kind of
go in i'm not going to wait for tv to
give me anything i'm going to make my
own thing and then people gravitate to
that
and
and it's that's your thing and and you
you can't mess with that whereas
i love that i love the fact that people
aren't going to be waiting for tv to
anoint them but i was very lucky that i
was just doing live gigs and then when i
was 26
after having done stand-up since i was
18 somebody said you want to go on tv
and i kind of went the traditional path
as it were and kind of
social media grew alongside it but i was
never
and i never needed it
which is not to say i couldn't have been
bigger if i
cultivated it but the content i like
making
exists in the club
and
it's finished when i do a netflix
special or it's finished when i do a tv
show it's it's in a state of flux
when i'm in a comedy club
um it's in a constant state of becoming
and the problem with social media it
makes everything
finite and tangible
and sometimes it's not sometimes jokes
evolve or routines evolve if you put it
out there it might be rubbish
or it might be ill-conceived it might
upset people
but by the end of it having worked in it
in a comedy club it might say exactly
what you want it to say it's a really
sort of
sort of holy space the comedy club
versus
versus twitter
why should you drink fuel we're going
into the fourth quarter of the year
diets are dropping off we're becoming
lazier and lazier and what tends to
happen when our diets dip and we start
to become less
compelled to go to the gym
is yeah we get out of shape we start to
feel low energy we start to binge eat
bad things and huel is the antidote it's
nutritionally complete so you get
everything you need for your diet in a
drink you get your 20 grams of proteins
you're going to get your 26 vitamins and
vitamins and minerals
it's low sugar high in fiber it really
is the cure to a lot of the health
issues that we see in our personal lives
but in wider society
if you've never tried it all i'll ask
you to do is give it a try and if you
like me then you will like the world
berry ready to drink you'll like the mac
and cheese which is just selling like
absolutely crazy unsurprisingly
um
you like the cinnamon
and you like the banana flavor those are
my recommendations i know a lot of
people love the chocolate flavor
let me know try it get yourself healthy
and send me a message on instagram tag
me on instagram as well on your stories
if you do try it out because i i
sometimes upload those tags
and let me know which is your favorite
flavor
as a comedian do you ever feel a sense
of imposter syndrome yeah i think i
don't know any
great comic that doesn't i'm not talking
to billy conley billy connolly
used to get nervous
billy connolly
was worried that the audience wouldn't
love him that he wasn't worth
the their evening
billy connolly if billy connolly is
thinking that then
you know you know all of us are and it's
i think if you get to that stage where
you're like this is going to be great i
know it's going to be great it probably
won't you have to have a healthy degree
of
of of imposter syndrome
in order to be the best version of
yourself because you have to kind of you
know you have to burst into that party
and be the best funniest you because
that's what's on the ticket that's the
thing and the only way to do that is
kind of hard work
you know um
but to to to just rock up for example to
an arena tour having done no kind of
warm-ups it'll be fine it [ __ ] won't
arrogance destroys stand up you kind of
have to
you have to go to small clubs before you
start doing a tour
to kind of know you're okay
to get rid of that
and without imposter syndrome
you uh you don't grow as an artist do
you know what i mean
but it can be tough to deal with
psychologically right because it sounds
like it must be similar to living with a
sense of like self-scrutiny which can be
quite
unhealthy i don't know
yeah
yeah what the i guess the
the key thing is to
you've got to i think you have to leave
on on your own terms
do you know what i mean as in stop
there's a there's a while where this
won't be healthy forever because it's
just it is a strange way to live
with that do you feel that you feel like
it won't be yeah yeah just because you
just kind of go there would just come a
time where you're
you're just you're not as sharp as you
once were and you're like fine i'll just
go work in local radio
but like
like not that's not a dig anyone in
local radio you do important stuff keep
those weather checks coming but
doing kind of arenas
for a long time is you know i've been
doing them since like 2012 now and that
is a crazy level of pressure because you
sort of do we do i do them in like a
month long block in the uk
and
it's kind of
right okay
yeah
you know and then you get through it and
then you're like okay go again go again
and that isn't necessarily
the healthiest way to be
forever
does it have mental health implications
on you because like if you're living
with that kind of internal fluctuation
all the time and that
anticipation that those feelings of
self-doubt that you know they say that
anxiety in particular is like concern
about the future if you're constantly
thinking about the future that moment in
that arena is
do you feel anxious at all well the
funny thing is the only time you don't
feel anxious is when you're doing the uh
when you're doing stand-up but weirdly
that's the that's the respite um
but the leading up to it it's
nerve-wracking but as soon as you step
on the uh on the stage you kind of you
know exactly what you're gonna do and
it's fun it's the most fun in the world
and then it's the but the leading up to
it
and the afterwards was that all right
was that fine it was good right
you know i think you sort of just make
your peace with it and you like you say
it's
it's
meant it leaves you mentally fragile but
i don't know of another way of doing it
have you suffered with anxiety though
yeah massively i like it sort of
but i think it's sort of that thing like
right i have these gigs if i don't do
this work
i'm gonna look like a fool people are
gonna boo me
there's going to be anger
so you go so that fear
drives you to write and perform and get
a show that's good enough right and i've
not found anything that was a useful
motivator but like you say it's a tough
way of of being like johnny wilkinson i
remember seeing this about him johnny
wilkinson kicked the
uh winning um
i don't know rugby but the winning world
cup will cut kick yeah right um
and
as the ball soared over
apparently he said to himself his brain
went you nearly missed that
as it went over like and he's won the
world cup and the next day
he was training
and he was kicking goals again to ensure
that he didn't make that mistake and
unfortunately
for him that's what makes him
magnificent
you know what i mean and i think it's
sort of that thing where you go
the older you get you can try and adapt
it and try and figure out and you know
and we're all in a constant state of
becoming as regards our sort of mental
health and trying to
um
figure out a healthier way of being the
best you without it being so draining
but he's got the winning goal of the
world cup
you know and it's sort of
it's kind of shitty but he but but that
determination is what sort of made him
and it's kind of
yeah i guess the thing is it's about
kind of ensuring that you have enough
kindness to yourself around that
so that you kind of give yourself a
break from time to time
and that the overall picture is happy
yeah but but but i don't know of a a
better motivator than fear to make good
stuff i like if if it exists i mean do
what do can you recognize that do you
have what what is there another thing
that you have
i guess excitement
if you could turn fear into excitement
that would be a healthier way of doing
it yeah but i just don't find it as oh
yeah it's so much fun because we'll go
there and it's gonna be great
but then you wouldn't do the prep right
as you say if i probably cited i
wouldn't i'd probably neglect
well that would be the thing so that so
you'd have like six months of joy yeah
and then you'd do the thing it'd be
[ __ ] awful and then whereas at least
this where you have six months of
tension
and then you have joy and then the kind
of joy lasts throughout the tour
and then after the tour and then after
the tour you go back to fear
to get there but but i don't know like
it but i i don't have the answers and i
i i don't know what works for other
people
but for me it is that and it's something
that i'm trying to address which is
like living in fear too living in fear
too much
or putting too much responsibility on
the thing
but i don't know of another way yeah
like you know and i'm sort of you know
seeing people and trying to figure it
out but i don't know
what motivates you for example it's i
completely get it it's a trade-off right
if you want to achieve the goal you need
this unfortunately i always think this i
think i think everything has a cost yeah
um and everything good in my life that i
love
comes with a cost it might be it could
even be a financial cost or it could be
some other type of sacrifice and those
that have risen the highest in certain
professions
it's so obvious to see the cost in their
lives it's much more obvious than
everyone say i sit here with my guests i
see it with eddie hearn he's built the
number one boxing promotion company but
he never ever sees his wife and kids
yeah and he's like
it's like unsatisfiable as a human yeah
you know that's why his book is called
relentless and i think well that's the
clear quote-unquote cost potentially
yeah um
and yeah with what you're saying being
in an arena performer
one would think that you spend a lot of
time in a certain mental
place which is uh not always great
yeah but then i was just thinking then i
was thinking about
the the fascinating thing about life is
you have these so for example we did 10
nights at the albert hall
which is like a world record it's mental
it was extraordinary that kind of little
me that used to sit in the back of mum
and dad's um
ford uh fiesta watching the raindrops go
down the window i did 10 nights at the
alcohol was mental um
and it was fun it's brilliant it's great
but it was like you're playing snooker
you know get all the reds
then
then knock the rest of them down done
you know what i mean but it's that
lovely kind of controlled snooker brain
end of the show hooray yeah go again
right but it was but it was fun that
exists from a sort of dopamine level on
a very similar
level
as
being on my stag do with my cousins in
vegas and hearing my cousin lewis tell a
story
and so i think it's
my
way of
figuring it out is to have as many
of those
dopamine hits of joy whether it's good
food good company
um travel books music whatever
so you're kind of constantly
feeding yourself like because if you
just that's the big realization i've had
that if you only try and get happiness
from work for me it doesn't work to sit
around and hope that your life outside
of work can compete with this joy that
you get from work the only way you can
do it is to surround yourself with
people that you think are fantastic
or experiences that you think are
fantastic
and it can even be little things it's
just like
you know
like we did some gigs in dubai and we
went to a water park every day and i'm
41 and i want my my friends who are all
big big lads and we were on this rubber
dinghy and we kept going down the slide
we honestly it was it was the joy the
silliness of the day
led into the the fun of the gig and i
remember reading a thing about chappelle
that chappelle
when he's on tour he brings his powers
he brings friends along so that he's
he's sort of living
the joy of life is connected with the
joy of work he's never sort of sat
backstage with his notepad
kind of waiting for an hour and a half
to go on and if that's something i'm
trying to do i'm trying to kind of
involve people
more in in kind of work and be less kind
of you need to stay away i need to
concentrate you know to blend the two
and you kind of totally yeah and you
talk about this is in the same way with
you
a couple of moments ago you talked about
living for the week and then kind of
like compartmentalizing that and then
having your life on the weekend and how
that doesn't feel like the best way to
live either because the you know five
days of misery and two days of like
pissed you know getting yeah
but i think also the pandemic has
recalibrated a lot of people that you
actually go we were kind of locked away
from each other and we were locked away
from experience
and
the happiness
of
something appearing from nowhere those
magical nights down the pub or watching
football or listening to music or having
a barbecue with friends where
a
moment
unintentionally becomes a memory and we
were kind of robbed of those social
moments that created memories because we
were sat
with this disease lurking not knowing
where our lives were going to become we
kind of felt like we were sort of immune
from something this
this heavy happening to us
and it didn't happen to everybody
and it feels like because of that
we we are now kind of coming out of the
cave as it were
with a real desire to
um
find as much
majesty in the universe as possible
that i genuinely feel a lot of people
like audiences post pandemic like even
british audiences
who are you know by a stretch the the
the toughest crowds in the world like by
a stretch is that that lovely english
coming in can't make me laugh yeah i
mean whereas like in america they're
they're already up you do comedy clubs
in america they stand up as you walk in
you know what i mean and
but but british crowds now
because people are people want
connection and they want experience
because it was kind of robbed of us
so um
it feels like it could be a really
glorious time and like like like you
were saying with the the tour that
you've got planned what a fantastic way
of doing that rather than just
i could just do you could just do a q a
but you're putting you know you're
making what sounds like a really
pulsating live theater show it's going
to blow people's minds
and
that's what
i want to do that's what audiences want
there's a friend of mine called alex
edelman who said i like stuff that's
ambitious and finished
and that's kind of where i
want to go and i feel like that's where
audiences want to be they want to see
something that's going to rock them
you know and
and and blow them away
what a target to aim for to a thing
that's going to be i'm going to try and
make a thing that's the best night out
that anyone's ever had
one of the things you said was um just a
couple of moments ago was that you've
seen someone to help you with uh that
kind of fear living in fear yeah state
that we described what do you mean by
you've seen someone oh just a bit of
therapy
to um yeah try and
uh um
have like sort of little coping
mechanisms
you know you sort of just get you get
far enough into it where you go maybe
just have a bit of help now
um to recognize kind of moments of mania
and how to kind of manage them a bit
better so nothing
super exciting it's not a shaman
or um you know it's not any kind of
ayahuasca or mushrooms it's just a bloke
in a in an office what was your
intention when you went to bloke in the
office um just to kind of make it a bit
easier so that you weren't
loading it too much so you can still
like you know
work
if efficiently without
it becoming debilitating because i think
that's the thing probably a lot of
people suffer from that by using fear as
a motivator sometimes
you're probably losing 20
of
your
potential through kind of um panic
so yeah it was sort of could i sound
like a [ __ ] robot when i said that
but you know what i mean it was sort of
that thing of like
just trying to figure out okay is there
another way of doing this
was that uh yeah it's but even
recognizing when you're
um
just a bit full-on and just kind of go
all right just calm down i'm a real
sucker for like little quotes man or i
was weirdly i'm interviewing will smith
on thursday
which is mad for 10 minutes i've got a
10 minute interview i'm so jealous they
they emailed me and said oh because we
have the same publisher like will smith
coming to town yeah i was like can i get
on the podcast he's like he's got no
time yeah i'd love 10 minutes well but
this is it well i'll sneak you along man
let's do it
but but
i was listening to the beginning of his
book
and um it's a brilliant story about his
dad made him and his
uh brother build a wall
and it's just this is very very simple
analogy you've probably read it it's
just brick by brick and that's
particularly when you're making a tv
show and you're writing topical jokes
sometimes well
sometimes it's really hard to make
stories interesting and to write jokes
about things that are going on and
in that instance this week that really
helped me break by brick and i'm able to
kind of go okay yeah cool i can i can
get stuff from that you know i'm i'm
very much a
from a philosophical point of view or a
therapy point of view i need
pointers and tips to make me better i'm
not uh enjoy every sandwich kind of a
guy because it's a [ __ ] sandwich
like i you know i mean like being the
sandwich just doing it's like fine it's
just a [ __ ] sandwich like i i need
i'm very much kind of eastern philosophy
of like okay how do we how do we make
ourselves better i love the idea of
kind of sort of self-improvement and
being the best you
um
so i find quotes help that you know
and even talking to somebody like that i
am like a bit of an expert
you he he'll say something or you'll say
something and you kind of unravel a
thing and even like what we're doing now
sort of having a chat
about
the process
and i have
my friend uh james bay
uh the singer we particularly during the
during kobe we spoke a lot about
uh everything and about creativity and
talking to like-minded individuals about
the pursuit of a joke or a gory song
or a
any kind of piece of art i find really
really interesting i love it i'm so
interested in the way that musicians
create i'm so envious because they sit
in a cool room or they go to like this
studio and they kind of write and they
jam and they riff and they create a
thing and then they perform it whereas
the musicians i know are very envious of
the way the comedians create which is
you go in front of a crowd
and you create with not for
you know
it would be like the comparison like
chris martin going in front of a crowd
and chiswick and going it was all blue
nope okay it was all green nope it was
all yellow yellow right i'll do yellow
tomorrow and it sort of is that kind of
process so talking to different
creatives or
anyone who is
sort of an expert in managing yourself
is
something that i find really comforting
or or
you know
like
even i've already gone to this quite
andrew huberman minute he's like a
professor from stanford and there's all
these kind of
neuro-linguistic things you can do to
help yourself
you know like cold showers and all this
and wim hof breathing and all this kind
of stuff does that stuff work
maybe it's psychosomatic but yeah it
feels like it does do you know what i
mean you feel like you've done your
it's like going to the gym it just feels
like medicine for you doesn't it you
always feel like no no one enjoys going
to the gym you know
i imagine arnold schwarzenegger did but
most people are just like right do it
and it feels like a nice little tick for
your soul
and it just feels like
therapy is almost well it's exactly that
isn't it it's a workout for your brain
or having a conversation like this is a
really nice workout for your brain where
we're both in kind of like a strange
dream-like state where we're kind of
having a deep conversation
we're kind of riffing
but somehow without planning any of this
we're getting to a deeper
place and yet it's very strange because
there's people
driving
listening to us right now
which is very weird it's weird
yeah and well that's the fascinating in
the future as well in the future man
yeah and but you're in the now aren't
you
derek left there but it's sort of that
fascinating thing that you let people
travel to work with you
it's the coolest yeah yeah it feels like
a huge yeah especially because it comes
out monday as well yeah which is a
particularly like interesting day to be
in their ear at six a.m yeah
and it's so funny is it what the podcast
you listen to what you're what you're
going through
do you listen to them look me up if you
found out like i listen to like serial
killer podcasts do you yeah like
theranose the trial of elizabeth holmes
like crime and serial killers tends to
be my like go-to yeah and you know what
it's actually i probably know why now
because i'm so fascinated this reason
why i do this podcast i'm so fascinated
by people in their psychology and for me
criminals and serial killers are the
most extreme and fascinating amongst us
so i would love to have a podcast where
i could interview circles and be like
why did you do that
yeah it's basically what i'm doing now
slightly different fascinations yeah
it's just i i get so fascinated by them
and i'm watching these serial killer
documentaries trying to understand the
pattern in what made them like from
their childhood and their dad said this
and then kid on the playground punched
him and then they just started killing
people yeah so yeah what about you
sort of more fantasy football stuff
really
[Music]
no i kind of um yeah
no no yes because a friend of mine does
one um
uh
yeah i listened to tim ferriss yeah and
andrew
huberman um
those are my go-to's mark maron i really
like yeah yeah uh says some really great
interviews
um
yeah i love there's a brilliant
interview with marin and seinfeld which
is one of my favorites
like i really got into jerry seinfeld
during the uh during the lockdown which
is kind of so late
do i mean i just feel like i've gone hey
radiohead are good um
but um
but yeah i kind of yeah that's my thing
i like i like hearing people that i
don't know and having my mind blown
that's what i like about podcast i'm not
into serial k i find it too
do you know what i mean to say that too
icky for me
what do you
always have
um one of the things you're touching on
there about these kind of
practical
hacks and quotes and stuff that allow
you to kind of get to a better place
reminded me of something that i read
about you regarding your pre-performance
routine and superstitions yeah before
you're going up on stage
and there's you know 15 000 people out
there and they've all got their arms
folded and demanding you to make them
laugh what are you doing backstage to
get yourself in the state you need to to
perform at your optimal
so if it's arenas we get football we
just have a kick around um really yeah
yeah so we just sort of do keep you ups
and you've got to do 10 before you go on
stage between oh okay so me kumar and
pete um and then steve and we'll try
we've got to do 10 keeping ups before we
go on stage can't really do that if
you're doing a small club
um there's a brilliant comedy club
called top secret in in london and um
it's very very small and before that you
i'm literally in an alley that thinks of
piss
um looking at notes
so so it's it's always looking at notes
thinking what you're gonna do sort of
trying to be calm to listen to that
inner voice
that says hey you could also do this
and that kind of weird
kind of um
funny that just appears from nowhere
that's always the best way of starting a
gig
um
and that's it really but there isn't
really a psyching up process i'll like
watch if i'm doing a big show watch my
friend who's who's supporting me
um
see what get
sneak in the back of the theater or the
arena and get a feel for them
and um
and then just go for it why keep your
ups is that just
tradition or is it like you know it's
just it's sort of if you're
this yeah there's maybe it's just that
weird thing of like right i've done ten
i can
you know
and then if you don't do ten the first
time and it falls you gotta do twenty
and if it falls thirty so you know i
mean so you you have to do it and then
it becomes this weird
uh like little thing
you just don't want that in the back of
your head you can't do a big gig going
[ __ ] man i only did 24 keep you ups
so
superstition yeah like yeah and i just
and i kind of like i spend a lot of time
with my tour manager kumar the mighty
kumar kamalagaran um and um just
chatting about stuff and just being kind
of loose and
sort of
yeah just sort of getting in the zone of
being silly and just talking about
any old bollocks to try and sort of get
things going or
you know it's like if my brother comes
on tour with me that's always fun
because it's kind of there'll just be a
bit of
a bit of nothing kind of happening and
like yeah so i like sort of just hanging
out and chatting talking bollocks and
um
sort of loosening yourself up really
that's kind of what i do beforehand
this is a very um i don't know why this
question came into my head but tends to
be the kind of things i ask on this
podcast what was the lowest moment of
your life
what was the lowest moment in my life
i think when my my when my grandad died
that was
like i was
it was yeah it was awful and i was
incredibly lucky because
i
i was i was thinking i was
36 when granddad died and um
he
i'd never had anyone in my family
um
well my cousin shane had died when i was
18.
and um
but i'd never been to a funeral so it
was shane and granddad so there'd been
this huge gap where nobody died
and um you know this sort of beautiful
family that i belong to they were all
kind of there
and my granddad was sort of like
unbelievably
special
kind of man he was four foot
nine
and um
just funny
and warm
and just like a quintessential grandad
but like he grant he got me into
football so i used to watch football
with granddad and watch match of the day
and he'd make me and daniel toast you
know that thick
white bread and he'd kind of like make
us some granddad toast
and he's just a brilliant
brilliant
soul that just was
such a big part of my life that he and
they used to come and see us quite a lot
whenever he was there
i don't know he was he was just bathed
in his love like him him and my nan just
adored me and i adored them and it was
they used to have a poster of of me on
there
uh
on their wall
um
and they used it and nan used to keep
all the
all the reviews i'd get so that she'd
put them up like and it was just that
only picked up some really some lovely
reviews and some shitty ones too and it
was just like man why are you don't take
that
what are you doing
but but they and they used to watch me
on tv and i come from a family where
it's inconceivable
that
that i could be on tv from from the
family that i come from it's it's
you know it's like going to the moon
but because
nana granted he said we'd watch you on a
tv mind we we'd watch it with the volume
downs you just swear
so they would watch me
when i was doing good news or i was on
mock the week with the volume down
it's our wrestling on the box and just
sort of see me kind of like that
and but they were so
through every part of my life i i felt
utter love from my nana my grandad and
they were around forever
and
and
it's it's that thing where
i don't know for whatever reason
he was like this sage
and
my there's a beautiful photo
of my cousin shane who who died when he
was he was 18. and he was on a scrambler
motorbike
and our granddad one mirror about eight
she used to look at that and just go
there you go that is the bravest bloody
boy you've ever seen in your life and it
was like
sort of a really interesting
um
story because he he had cancer
and
he died of cancer and he
he
went on this sort of scrambler and he
did this race
and he was he completed it even though
he was really not well at all
and and our granddad told that was such
pride and it was this beautiful story
and that's what and granddad and you
knew grandma told similar stories
obviously not as beautiful as that about
all of us
and and um
yeah when he died it was just this
sledgehammer to your heart where you
just go
jesus one of the
one of the
one of the good souls isn't here anymore
and yet this is the
the fascination of life i was in mexico
and it happened and my mum ran me up and
said granddad's dead i'm so sorry
[Music]
just look
[Music]
um
literally seconds later there was a
there was a mexican man
and it was just like
[ __ ] me the universe is funny man so it
was like utter sadness and then
something
and it was um
yeah it was
just this weird
like moment where you're like going
[ __ ] really really
um so yeah that was that was definitely
an unbelievably low moment and yet
weirdly became
his funeral
this beautiful moment where you were
like i said at the beginning where you
feel privileged to belong to the blood
you belong to
you know i've never done who do you
think you are i know who i am i'm you
know
i know where i come from and i know my
people and i feel
proud to belong to those people
um
and the funeral
of my grandma was just this reminder of
the excellence of my family and how
proud and how much we all love each
other
so from that deep sadness
came this reflection of my granddad and
you realized that everyone in this room
were there because of his brilliance
so it was this kind of weirdly
bittersweet moment you know
and my cousin
my cousin stewart wore a leather jacket
and looked like [ __ ] lovejoy
and nobody understood
and everyone said why are you wearing a
leather jacket oh we know we didn't have
a suit
and we were carrying granddad in the
coffin and daniel was like nice jackets
do and our [ __ ] shoulders start going
because it's like you know like oh mate
and everyone's like they're gonna laugh
and we're like i can hold it together
hold it and then um yeah six weeks later
my nan died and uh it was horrific six
weeks later yeah six weeks later and
then we went to the um
went to the funeral again and stuart
rocked up with that same leather jacket
and you're like [ __ ] me man and you
could see everybody just looking down
going don't laugh why is he wearing a
[ __ ] lever he literally rocked up
like hasselhoff you're like put a suit
up but it was
weirdly funny and you could everyone go
[ __ ] leather jack i want to get my
jesus christmas [ __ ] wrong with it
but
um like was all flapping and that um but
and i i had to do the eulogy for my
granddad as well and that is something i
put
deep deep deep
deep time into to make it and i that you
know and obviously you can't get it
right you can't express what he meant to
you but um yeah that was the there was a
long answer to the lowest moment but
yeah
they they say um people can pass away
from heartbreak yeah
is
for your grandmother to die six weeks
following yeah i think yeah i think they
would they would you know
joined at the hip yeah they used to just
kind of
yeah
yeah maybe it was that it was just kind
of
yeah it was just but also there was such
constants and i just wasn't
i'd never really been exposed to death
and it was just this kind of like to for
it to arrive quite late in your life it
was just a real like whoa
yeah and then you lose and then you've
suddenly lost your nan and your granddad
who would kind of
like we got like
my nana's particularly just
such a lovely she's got proper
sort of blue grey hourly eyes you know
and she's always started tucking her
sort of shirt down and she just come in
and just tell you little she goes
they're just weird little [ __ ] so i
remember doing my dissertation she was
staying around her house and she said
what are you doing i said i'm doing
a um i'm doing my dissertation now and
she what about i said it was about
whether it's right or wrong to advertise
to children
and my nan went yes no
well i gotta do ten thousand views
so you know this is not there is it come
on coming off your tails i i i can't
just put it's not nancy veil i gotta do
this
but she was very strange we used to make
flapjacks together as kids as when i was
a kid and she was obviously man but um
we didn't
like flapjacks
and
we used to just make them as a thing and
then put them in the bin [ __ ] weird
yeah i know yeah and the reason we kept
doing it is because it really annoyed my
mum because she's like what are you
doing jesus christ what's wrong with you
and then she would get the flapjacks out
the bin
and that was funny watching my mum eat
flapjacks from a bin but i got a weird
family man but
but
um
yeah that those were the uh i wonder if
she did die from heart like i don't know
i mean she
you know they weren't particularly well
towards the end of their life as well
they sort of had kind of you know the
certainly
the beginnings of dementia
so um
yeah it was kind of you know it's that
horrible thing where
yeah i don't know it's just kind of
yuck in it you know
how about you what's the lowest moment
in your life am i allowed to ask yeah um
the lowest moment of my life
good question
is it shitty to ask you no it's no like
if if i can ask someone else if they
have to okay i don't even it's a really
interesting question um
i think it would probably be i know i
know what it is
it's the one that kind of stands out to
me is really really sucking so
my grandmother dying was one of them but
i wasn't close to her right so it was
just actually seeing my dad upset seeing
you like dad cry for the first time was
very like oh yeah isn't that a if you
have you got a strong dad yeah yeah
never seen him be emotional yes that's
the weirdest thing he's quiet passive
just
and then you know to see him cry is yeah
that's very difficult to understand as a
kid
and then the other one is actually when
my dad
called me into his bedroom and told me
he didn't love my mum
oh wow and that they were going to get a
divorce and they didn't get a divorce
they're still together now but at seven
i think i was when he said that to me it
was like earth like foundation
shattering information that i couldn't i
don't know i always remember that i
didn't always
recall that one you know it's like i
could never forget that moment in my
life what are you meant to do with that
seven [ __ ] exactly
especially when it doesn't even happen
but um their relationship for me was so
toxic as a kid that i actually got to a
point later where i'd come to terms with
the illusion being burst that your
parents actually might not stick
together and then i was actually willing
them to get a divorce because they were
just screaming at each other too much so
yeah
i think that's probably that's for some
reason those two moments came to mind um
if i told you that you could never write
a joke again and you could never perform
again yeah
what would happen to you
i don't know it's
hmm
think you'd go back to you i'd end up
being what i was when i was younger of
just desperately trying to make people
laugh and
and
just sort of
just be a
a bit of a nuisance at tesco do you know
what i mean when you're kind of getting
your shopping you're like you're right i
was looking at a sperm donor the other
day
oh you should have six foot four like
you know what i mean it's kind of you
know so i think
why
i don't know i just like making people
laugh a lot i like the
i like
it makes me feel good and it it um
yeah it just makes me feel good i i kind
of it's like i say it feels like you're
giving them a socially accepted orgasm
every time they laugh so you're
literally going going around
making people come
why don't
why tesco yeah
imagine making someone come in tesco but
why why don't i every little help
here we go
[Music]
but why don't that's the new advert for
christmas
i'm sorry go on carry what we're gonna
say
but why don't why do you have that that
need and i like i don't so if you said
to me i could never write a joke again
or i could never you know perform comedy
again
i would find like my life would be
unchanged but for you yours would be
it'd be like an irritant
what's the difference well it's the same
as you like saying you know you can't
you can't have your own business
yeah you've got what's you've got to
work for somebody else mm-hmm so
how's that how does that feel for me
it's it's a definite loss of purpose
yeah for me it's like a huge loss of
purpose
um not so much working with someone else
but not being able to like build
yeah do what i do professionally it
would be this huge sense of
like loss of purpose i might move on to
like
doing shows or like just writing books
all the time or something else
but
from a comedic perspective it's like
what you're doing is like very reliant
on feedback of sorts so i'm wondering
where that's like coming from is that
you know we kind of touched on it
earlier in the conversation it's just
yeah it's been it's been such a clear
consistent coping mechanism in the
toughest moments of your life evidently
um that it makes me ponder
how you would cope without that coping
mechanism dealing with the reality of
life you know you but i think that's
what i said laughter is the lubricant
that makes life livable life is life is
tough and laughter provides respite
um
for me and it
and and that's and it's so deeply human
everyone has has irrespective of whether
you have a
an easy blessed life everyone has had
moments of trials and tribulations and
laughter is just a it's a
it's a thing that soothes us
and i find it particularly soothing that
you take the the sting out of pain
by just making
making it funny do you know what i mean
and it's kind of it just works for me i
just find laughing
or making people laugh just the best
because you in in the moment of laughter
you're lost you are not of this realm
you're you're kind of in this
white noise space
um
and it's good it's it's a it's a good
place to be escapism almost yeah yeah
but exactly see and then you come back
to kind of reality and
you're you're a little bit more
reconfigured or you it lightens the load
a bit you know and and and i
get a deep sense of satisfac
satisfaction from
making people laugh
so and you're right it is tied up in
them
you know it's very needy that's
absolutely true
but then
you know i'm 41 now and i kind of know
who i am i'm kind of needy most comics
are
because i've been asked to write
sort of my autobiography quite a few
times and it's like
i just don't
feel like
sitting and entertaining myself
um
whereas when you're writing stand up
you're writing it for
an audience so you can perform or you're
making notes and you go hey i'll take
that on stage and i'll kind of riff it
out and figure it out with them whereas
a book to me just feels like it would be
i don't think i've got these skills to
sit down and try and
entertain myself and then eventually
entertain
people through the book do you know what
i mean like i did a thing
last year where we went to australia and
new zealand during the pandemic um
because we're doing some gigs out there
and we stayed in the hotel for two weeks
and
we made a stand-up show
that blended me meeting people
alongside stand-up and it was it was one
of the most satisfying things i've ever
done we met these incredible women in
new zealand there's a thing called the
coughing club and what they do is i
didn't know this turns out um
dying is really expensive
and coffins are really pricey and what
these retired pensioners do they make
cheap coffins
and they kind of sell them for like
you know 300 bucks
really kind of low don't make any profit
so these beautiful funeral elves
and they make their own coffins as well
um just for as a bit of fun and i met
this lady and she'd made three coffins
for herself and i was like how come she
made three so i just keep putting on
weight
and and it was so touching and peculiar
and and then we went into another room
and there were little baby coffins tiny
tiny and it's one of those things that
you i hope nobody ever sees that and i
was like how and people often say oh
comedy hardest job in the world imagine
making a coffin for a baby it blew my
mind and i looked at this twinkly-eyed
lady i was like how do you do that
how do you get yourself in a place to
make something that sad and she kind of
looked at me and just went i do it so no
one else has to
and it was so beautiful
and for me
i
i loved being able to tell that story
through stand-up with her on the show
and i don't know if i have the skills
to
tell that story
um through words on a page
yeah do you know what i mean i'm sort of
aware
of a
an ability i have as a communicator to
make a story like that deeply human i
could tell that in front of anybody and
it gets to their heart it's so pure and
there's so many stories out there like
that the the trying to find those
examples of magnificence
um
i find endlessly
interesting but you don't find them if
you sat down writing a book you got to
get out there and you you've kind of got
to put yourself in peculiar situations i
met a lady that goes yowie hunting turns
out there's a yowie is a big eight-foot
sort of like abominable snowman in
australia
that he lives just outside brisbane she
was absolutely wonderful right you know
mad as a box of frogs but beautiful and
she was like yeah what we do put some
cigarettes out and some beer that should
lure him in like so no she puts this big
jacket on me she goes yeah and you might
want to make the mating noise and i'm
like how does that go and she's like
sort of like oh like i'm kind of lit
inching in the field going
and she's like yeah you're doing really
well and then i
panic
because i start going
what if this is real
and suddenly this eight-foot bloke comes
along and [ __ ] me like that and and i'm
sort of dragged off and you're like
and then it was so and i was telling her
this and we're laughing and it's funny
that that again
those stories i love trying to find
those stories so i feel like i don't
have enough
stories yet to sit down and tell them
all
and the great thing about stand-up you
can rotate your stories they go hey do
you want to hear this hey do you want to
hear that you know or things can happen
from nowhere my brother is an ex like we
were
we were having a conversation with a
friend of mine recently and from nowhere
my brother goes
uh what because this bloke was talking
about his friend he goes yeah he's a vet
my brother goes yeah to be a vet you've
got a shoot a car in the face and i'm
like what are you talking about he goes
yeah it's the only way you can be a vet
if you've shot a kid in the face i said
is it what so they do six years of
school and then right at the end they
give him a smith and weston and they
blast him in the face and he's like well
don't give him that you thick [ __ ] they
give him a bolt gun
i'm going to shoot him with a rifle
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that so we're having
this kind of conversation and i'm like
what are you talking about it goes true
kez told me oh kez told you he knows no
it's a bit short in face
says by that now weirdly a month later
i'm doing a gig in leicester there's a
guy chatting away and he's he's a he's a
vet
and i go for this i gotta ask
did they make you shoot cows in the face
and he goes yeah yeah we have to it's
one of the things the [ __ ] was right
so i ring my brother up in the middle of
this gig there's 2 000 people there i
ring him up and i'm like and put him on
speaker on the phone i go you're right
he goes yeah what and i go i'm just in
leicester i'm a gig oh yeah and i go um
yeah you know that thing you were saying
about cow
and vets yeah it turns out you were
right and he went yeah i know
and he goes listen i gotta go and watch
him vigil
like that [ __ ] up but that was the
correct story for that night is is my
point that that that sometimes
and it was so hilarious in that moment
it couldn't have been more perfect yeah
yeah and then all the ushers the work
there and go that was planned right
but it was but it only came about
because me and my brother were with
friends of mine in exeter he told a
man's story i had an argument with him
we all laughed because my brother was
talking [ __ ] what's he on about a month
later i meet
you know a vet he
agrees with my brother
and um
and we have a moment of magic and it's
and it's the funny thing that that's all
anyone would remember from that show
um
and i i i i don't have the skills to do
that through sitting on my own i would
be too excited to tell people the story
quick one as you probably know by now
i'm trying to make my life a little bit
more sustainable and i consider myself
to be on a bit of a sustainability
journey in the same way that i'm on a
health journey
and it's a privilege to be able to share
that with all of you and you you all
know if you've listened to the last
podcast that i traded in my range rover
sport in for an electric bicycle which
is now my only vehicle and next year
hopefully i'll have my electric car too
if tesla hurry up with a cyber track and
that's where my energy comes into my
life and my sort of sustainability
journey it makes your life if you are on
that sustainability journey 10 times
easier this is one of the if you can't
see this i'm holding up my hand if
you're listening on spotify apple this
is one of their renewable energy
products if you're watching on youtube
you'll you'll see this this is called
the harvey it's this very clever little
device that allows the zappy and the
eddy which i've talked about before on
this podcast to be installed into your
home without hard wiring or without
batteries or without those um god-awful
transformers that a lot of people have
in their house it's basically a tiny
device that's going to save you both
time and money and for someone like me
who doesn't have loads of time on our
hands it's a real life saver if you're
looking to make a conscious switch and
you need a quick fix that's going to
save you a load of time then head over
to myenergy.com to see this product and
many many more
so patrice evra yes who sat there before
jimmy carr said one day his girlfriend
turned him and was like
are you happy
and he and at first he like resisted
that question because it makes people
feel a little bit uncomfortable
but um
yeah are you happy
um
yeah at this moment yeah i've
really enjoyed this chat like deeply
and um
i feel pumped up and energized so yeah
but it's back to what i'm saying i'm
kind of
i need the energy of others
to make me happy
you referred to when i asked that
question you referred to this moment as
if
happiness was more of a mood in your
view versus than like a long-lasting
state and if we say if we were to say
that it was a state a long lasting sort
of a baseline would you say you're happy
um
yeah i'd say i have more
i have more moments of happiness than
sadness and then so but but i'm in a
state of flux with that like you know i
can be super low and super
uh
sort of
depressed about oh [ __ ] how the jokes
are [ __ ] this week in the show god i've
got they haven't got the stuff you know
what i mean so i kind of i can let
things get on top of me
um
but i have more
moments of happiness and sadness i think
have you ever experienced what they call
like depression like clinical
depression
um in your view
i don't no i don't think so um i
you know i have moments of like where
you can't you know
you be sort of aware you need to shift
it but i'm very much at right get on the
treadmill lift some weights um kind of
uh
do something kind of a guy i'm restless
you know um but uh yeah i've never been
you know diagnosed or anything like that
but uh
but yeah how about you you happy
such a heavy question right it's a
really heavy question i remember the
first time my uh [ __ ] patrice evra
yeah i know right yeah what an
interesting fascinating bloke he is as
well which is crikey
remarkable remarkable guy
am i happy i remember the first time i
was asked it and it felt really
uncomfortable and i felt defensive about
the question yeah my pa who was also my
girlfriend at the time and he has a long
story we weren't going to that um she
asked me in the car one day she was like
are you happy
i was like how dare you i mean that's
not right no of course not but i think
like my ego
inside my chimp brain probably was like
how [ __ ] dead like of course i am um
i believe so yeah i believe so um and
one of the things that i have helped me
a lot is i'm very obsessed with
gratitude
and like constantly reminding myself of
like how unbelievably fortunate i am to
be
one of the free ones and what i mean by
that is like financially free free to do
what i choose to most days um
of course i have days where it sucks and
my mood's shitty and like i'm irritable
and i'm a bit of an [ __ ] to be around
but
um
i feel i feel somewhat content um
despite my relentless uh excruciating
ambition
yeah
yeah that's a very good answer
i'll take that one okay
your manager said you're you're the
hardest working comic he's he's ever met
right
yeah well i just like is that toxic
people in this in our society at the
moment of this is kind of stigma around
people that work too hard that it's you
know
toxic productivity or yeah but it's it's
sort of
you know you work as something you love
so it's kind of like
you know
it's it's sort of those moments of like
you just lose yourself in it it's like i
imagine it's the same with
when picasso
was painting do you know me and he was
just probably like
this is fun like do you know what i mean
like you know imagine is i'm not
comparing myself to picasso i'm using
him as an example of just sort of
imagining his is manager going you need
to [ __ ] relax mate
i mean the system trap will happen but
it's just i don't know i just
i love it and i don't
um i don't mind working hard it's all
and it's also it's not it's not working
in the in the true sense like you just
said how fortunate to be one of the
three ones well like it's ridiculous
like i'm i write the t i write stand up
on my own but i do i do my tv show and i
write it with
um
five people and um
we get to write jokes that is our job
there's an unbelievably
privileged job to be able to sit around
and think of funny things for people
and that can be stressful but there are
people working in
um
in jobs that they don't like that would
kill for that opportunity so you're
right you need those moments to kind of
snap yourself out of your funk
and um
and remember that you're getting paid to
do a hobby
ultimately you know
in my case um
and in mind like this is yeah totally
but but
but my point being it's sort of like
there's no
there's nothing wrong with having low
moments and everyone does and it feels
like the world is better
now
in terms of being a talk about them
but you also i think
if you come from a certain background
you don't want to [ __ ] and moan about
yourself and kind of say that you're
having a tough time or whatever but
if you're lucky enough to have friends
that you can talk to
um or things like this or a therapist or
whatever just may it makes
the
pursuit of happiness a lot easier i
think because i think that is pos maybe
that's what happiness is it's about
talking
for long enough
to realize what you have
whether that is a loving relationship
whether it's a job you love
whether it's a hobby you adore but there
will there will always be
sort of shimmering
lights of hope in in the misery but
sometimes somebody has to help you find
them i think
do you know what i mean because i think
it's very difficult to sit within
yourself and go yeah i can see
everything's fine sometimes you need a
little bit of help
to kind of remind you of how lucky you
are
your upcoming netflix special you called
it lubricant i now know why yeah yeah
but tell me what we can expect from this
special in and how it was conceived and
what makes it you know
i guess
worth watching
wow um
it is
the best
stories and jokes that i've written in
the last two years
from traveling around the world i did a
tour that was called respite
and i kind of put together all the best
bits about
kind of
conspiracy theories and uh
uh covid and leadership and
madness
in the world and i sort of splodged it
all together and the
you never quite know what it is until
you sort of step away from it and i
think it's actually a love letter to
laughter that's what the show is and
it's the the full hour is about the
the importance
of of giggling and of being silly
and
how deeply human it is and
and it should be treasured there's a bit
in the in the
where i
i was chatting about you know when you
hear somebody play a musical instrument
and you're envious of the notes they're
making it strikes me that laughter is a
musical instrument that any one of us
can play
and now is not the time to put down our
[ __ ] trumpets
and it that's what if that's the show
really it's about the importance of
laughter and and the role it plays in
which
we do life um and it's lots of funny
stories that are kind of all about that
really you talked about how as a
comedian you have to kind of have this
like self-evolution
what what evolution in the comedian that
you are in this special lubricant
have you observed in yourself
um i'm slower and i'm um more thoughtful
and i try and make it more
interesting for people sat at home
than
in the room i think previously i've been
a bit too kind of high octane and i'm
trying to kind of make it pleasurable
for people at home so they can sit and
enjoy it because that's how it
ultimately is consumed i have a
fascination with anger and i have a
fascination with with beauty i don't
like so i find anger strange
and i find beauty beguiling and that is
only getting deeper and deeper so for
example that story about the ladies in
the coffins that isn't in this show
but it's
it's somewhere deep in me
and i think that will come out in
another show so it's sort of
the evolution as a comedian for me is
that i want the next
special on the next tour that i do to be
deeply
human and i want it to be this
in in in in the best sense a place where
you can [ __ ] nod with me or and laugh
with me and feel
like this connection with people next to
you
and i think that comes through
the ex
through exploring how [ __ ] weird and
silly we all are
i think
i think the world's taking itself very
seriously at the moment
and um
there's so much humor in it
i think there's so much humor in the
on the edges on in the shades of serious
stuff do you know what i mean i kind of
find it uh
yeah that's kind of what that's where it
feels like my evolution is that i'm
trying to kind of i try and talk about
you know i quite like being able to talk
about serious stuff for example you know
we you know talk about cancer culture or
woke like the amount of times you hear
the word woke in newspapers at the
minute
and it's because it just sells it sells
papers man and it's kind of like hey
have you seen what they've done
you can't say the word farts and and
boobies and arse in scrabble that's the
story in the newspaper
and it was like furious woke scrabble
bosses no one's furious about scrabble
no one's like just and even if they were
doing that how are they going to police
it i was going to you know
break into your house you go did you put
[ __ ] on a triple letter they're not
going to do that so i find that
mechanism
really interesting at the moment that
you go okay clearly there's money to be
made in
kind of you won't [ __ ] believe what
they've done now that in in that energy
but also recognizing that it's just a
trick it's a big outrage it's fake
outrage and it's kind of it's the what
next brigade and i but i find that
really interesting that was like piers
morgan's whole thing for a while on tv
it was like they've changed toilets to
unisex
[ __ ] yeah but because it it sort of
like it just it works it's easy it's
click and then you and you're there but
it's kind of not it it's just not
nourishing and there is actually a way
of of of making the people that are that
succumb to that and the people that
think it's [ __ ] you can bring them
together through really pissed funny
stories um or true like that story about
the coffin and the the lady
doesn't matter your political
orientation doesn't matter your gender
whatever
that's a deeply funny human story and
like you look at someone like billy
connolly
like like some of his bits are so
beautiful and funny with george carlin
that that they're
they're majestic and you're kind of lost
and i think there's a real value to to
humor and it's it's often overlooked
because it is silly
and it is kind of fart pissed [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know what i mean it's kind of
you know what i mean it's fingers and
ears and
yeah but it it's it's a release and it's
kind of
it's a deeply important thing laughter
deeply deeply important and if we didn't
have it you know like i think it's only
like dolphins and rats are the only
animals that laugh
i don't know how scientists found that
out i know i do actually they tickle the
rat's bellies with a pencil this is
presumably pre-coveted
imagine that if it's just kind of
vaccine i'm busy just kind of
trying to get this rat to giggle but um
but yeah so that's lubricant that's it
december 14th december the 14th comes
out and it was it was respite um that's
it's the it was to show respite and then
right at the last minute i decided to
call it lubricant
uh but that becomes a pl i mean we all
know now listening to this why it's
called that but it's kind of 40 minutes
in you go all right
there might be some furious perverts
who were kind of going where's there's
absolutely nothing here about like about
vaseline
about ky jelly this is it's bereft of
any
lubrication perhaps someone writes in
yeah that is the review this is not what
you think it is it's absolutely
disgusting i was [ __ ] outraged and
then you've got until the wheels come
off as well which is a documentary so
yeah so until the wheels come off is a
documentary about making a stand-up
special throughout the cove pandemic so
yeah it was kind of
uh yeah so cameras followed us around
and tried to
you know like we did gigs in football
stadiums and car parks and craziness
yeah it was brilliant
but we did ashton gate uh which is the
home of bristol city um and we had to
get 2 000 people
in a
uh 10 000 seater stand
they all had to be spread out and it was
one of the weirdest gigs i've ever done
but it's won the best and that comes out
on the same day so the then the the doc
is on the same day so special so yeah
well yeah we have one i'm excited for
both i actually did get the chance to
watch the trailer all right nice and it
was hilarious oh thank you and that's um
i'm particularly excited to see someone
with your smarts and both comedic genius
and intellect take on
recent times yes that makes sense yeah
totally i'm most excited about and
so really really looking forward to that
on december 14th we have a long-standing
tradition on this podcast where the
previous guest as i mentioned writes a
question for the next guest so patrice
wrote are you happy because that was the
question that stumbled upon
i don't i'm not going to say who the
person was that's written this for you
okay but i'm gonna tell you what the um
the question is um
what three things would you give to the
world
you can only answer with single words to
make it happier
jesus
jesus is not okay um that's one
what three things would i give to the
world to make it happier you can only
answer with one one one one words
answers
i mean this is a real reverse aladdin
moment isn't it
a um climate
you know that's two words but
you know
that's the first thing
technology that stops
mental health
so you zap them
and they're fine
it's just sort of a wand you wait for
them
mental fund yeah so yeah a mental amen
yeah so that's it fixed climate mental
health wand
and
food
yeah
yeah i feel like fixed climate mental
health wand
food and starvation
and starvation it will end starvation
yes right
now i was gonna say [ __ ] me i give and i
take now i'm going to ask you to do the
same but before i do that i just want to
say a huge thank you for coming today
because i've watched you on screen for
many many many years i find you
hysterical but also i i love this
opportunity to get to know a side of you
that i wouldn't have ordinarily seen on
screen because of the way that you know
the format of tv and a depth in you and
you're just again you're super smart
super introspective you're a genius
clearly and um you're doing a service to
the world which is clearly so
unbelievably self selfless in cheering
people up at a time when they really
need it that uh i feel like the
comedians amongst us who are lubricating
us through these hard times are national
treasures at the moment so thank you
mate what a sweet thing i need you to
come home and
say that whenever i'm having
problems with my
but it's time to write a question
[Music]
you